hi i'm daniel i'd like to share some
thoughts about how causality can help us
build robust machine learning models for
medical imaging there's been growing
awareness among healthcare regulators in
the scientific community of the need for
responsible reporting and machine
learning for health care
and has been increasing efforts to
outline best practices for the safe
development and monitoring of ai enabled
technologies
this has been accompanied by a surge in
discussion in the medical community
about the opportunities but also
crucially the risks of deploying these
tools in clinical practice
most of the apprehension is around their
external validity and that means how
well these models generalize outside the
control development environment
in particular the concerns are about
whether the training data is
representative of the target population
whether we have access to enough machine
learning ready annotated data
whether this data is actually reliable
for training a model and whether the
task that we're trying to address is
actually confounded by some process that
we're not accounting for
now the key here is that causal
reasoning gives us a systematic way of
understanding and communicating these
challenges
now let me walk you through two clinical
examples to help hopefully make this
more concrete
the first example is about developing a
brain tumor segmentation model for
clinical use
here we have data from a cohort of adult
glioma patients that's a type of brain
cancer and we've had a team of
radiologists manually segment the lesion
on mri scans for planning delivery of
radiotherapy
here we foresee differences in the
prevalence of this type of cancer across
age groups
and there might also be different types
of mri scanners in routine clinical use
and these kinds of differences are known
to often degrade the performance of
machine learning models in practice
now more generally there can be
differences in various external factors
across environments so not just the
disease prevalence and image acquisition
like here but also relating to
demographics and the annotation process
itself
second example i'd like to cover is on
detecting skin cancer from thermoscopic
images these are close-up pictures of
skin lesions and we're trying to predict
cancer diagnosis as determined by a
biopsy
the tricky thing in this example is that
not every patient gets a biopsy only
suspicious cases
and this means that benign-looking
lesions will be under-represented in
this dataset
and this is an example of sample
selection bias and that's a
data-dependent process that determines
what's included in the data set and then
multiple possible mechanisms like the
care pathways in the hospital like in
this case but also manual interventions
in the data relating to data curation or
quality control for example
now putting it all together we can
actually formulate a detailed
characterization of data mismatch
i'm not going to go into a lot of detail
here this is just to illustrate that
causality provides a precise language to
articulate assumptions about files and
mechanisms in the data generating
process
and this in turn helps us to identify
mitigation strategies for training
reliable models in high-risk
environments like healthcare
so to make this more directly practical
for the community we formulated this
little checklist here
and it's this starts with uh going
beyond just the typical machine learning
paradigm of input and output and really
trying to understand the context of the
problem so we then able to answer these
questions about the data generating
process
and then we will be in a position to
draw a diagram representing these
assumptions which enables transparent
communication but also critique and then
we can scrutinize these assumptions and
see how we can improve the models
finally we can walk through this graph
to identify the various
bias pathways that underlie this data
generating process and then
establish corresponding strategies to
mitigate them
so just to summarize what i want you to
remember is that understanding the
causal story of the data is crucial for
the safe development of healthcare ai
you can find more details in our paper
thank you for listening
you